[Music]
allow me to tell you the classic
children's tale of Chicken Little
otherwise known as Henny Penny as the
tale goes little Henny was outside one
day when an acorn fell from a tree and
hit her on the head because of her
naivete and simplemindedness Henny
foolishly began to believe that the sky
itself was falling down around her she
spent the rest of the day trying to
convince others like goosey loosey and
turkey-lurkey that the sky was most
certainly falling and the world was
surely coming to an end in most versions
of the story the trip does not end well
for Henny and her hysterical friends
after they meet the sly Foxy Loxy I
don't want to give everything away
though so either read the story for
yourself or check out the classic season
6 episode of The Golden Girls in which
they reenact the tale I mention Henny
and Lucy and Turkey and foxy not just
because they're great names to say but
because it seems that just about
everyone is telling us the sky is
falling these days between Trump Russia
North Korea we've got about half the
country that's in total freakout mode
every day this freak out takes on a new
urgency one day the world is ending
because America left the Paris climate
Accord another day it's because of the
net neutrality reversal and another day
it's because Trump holds his water glass
with two hands this endless hysteria is
not only being amplified by the media
but it's actually being poked and
prodded by them as well
blue cheque verified journalists on
Twitter who work for news organizations
which really are nothing more than
partisan activist outlets want to keep
you clicking on their articles and
videos and they know that the best way
to do that is to convince you that not
only is the sky falling but it's gonna
land directly on your head what if and
just hear me out on this one
this outrage Factory is completely wrong
and the world isn't coming to an end
just yet crazy I know but I think that
it actually might be true this doesn't
mean that things are perfect but they
are pretty damn good this is the
position of my guest this week Harvard
psychology professor Steven Pinker
Pinker argues despite our world of
perceived horror and chaos people are
living longer happier healthier and
freer
lives right now more than any other time
in human history this doesn't mean we
don't have work to do but if we don't
stop and smell the roses we might toss
away all the goodness humans have
created for the prospect of a utopia
that will never appear this is why I'm
so proud of the work we've done here on
the Rubin report I truly believe that
the conversations were having are at
least some part of the antidote to the
craziness right now if those of us who
care about enlightenment principles like
science reason and natural rights can
make our voices louder than this cliff
we seem to be about to go off of might
just turn into a bridge to a better
world Henny Penny story took a drastic
turn when she met Foxy Loxy who tricked
her and her friends to go to his lair
well in real life we've got a Wolf
Blitzer in a Situation Room if the sky
is falling maybe just changing the
channel is all we have to do to survive
the day
[Music]
you